THE JANUARY FIFTEENTH ELECTIONS
AND REDISTRICTING COMMITTEE
HEARING THERE ARE TWO BILLS ON
OUR AGENDA TODAY NOTHING IS ON
CONSENT ONE BILL AB TWELVE
FORTY FIVE BY LOW IS ON THE
AGENDA FOR VOTE ONLY THE BILLS
THAT ARE UP IN COMMITTEE WE-
WE'RE GONNA START WITH ITEM ONE
ON THE AGENDA WHICH IS A. B.
TWELVE SEVENTY SIX. ON TO. AND
MR BONTA READY WHENEVER. A
QUORUM SO WE'RE STARTING AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE IS GARLIC PERFECT
LOW RUSTY BUT I'M I'M GETTING
THAT. EARLY IN THE YEAR YES.
HAPPY NEW YEAR EVERYBODY THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES IN A STAFF FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT AB
TWELVE SEVENTY SIX WHICH IS A
CLEANUP BILL TO A LOCAL
REDISTRICTING REFORM BILL AB
EIGHT FORTY NINE THAT CAME TO
THIS COMMITTEE AND THE AUTHOR
LAST WAS SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR
THAT IS KNOWN THE FAIR AND-
REDISTRICTING FROM HIS
APOLOGIES EMPLOYEE. SUBDIVISION
ACT A NEW CAR TRANSPARENCY AND
CATION AS WELL AS FEAR OF
DRAWING OF DISTRICT LINES AB
TWELVE SEVENTY SIX ADDS BACK
LANGUAGE THAT WAS NEGOTIATED
DURING THE DRAFTING OF AB EIGHT
FORTY NINE BUT AMONG THAT
TACKLE STAKEHOLDERS BUT WITH
INADVERTENTLY LEFT OUT OF THE
BILL THIS ALSO CLARIFIES
EXISTING LAW GOVERNING THE
REDISTRICTING PROCESS IN A FOR
CONSTITUTIONAL AUTONOMY. CHOP
CITIES OVER CERTAIN ASPECTS OF
THE REGION TESTING AB TWELVE
SEVEN EXTRA I'M CONTROVERSIAL
CLEAN UP THE AB EIGHT FORTY
NINE AND WITH ME IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWELVE SEVENTY SIX IS NICOLE
WONG A COMMUNITY ADVOCATE FOR
THE VOTING RIGHTS PROBE AT THE
ASIAN LOCK AS WELL AS THE STYLE
STAFF ATTORNEY AND PROGRAM
MANAGER FOR THE VOTING RIGHTS
CENSUS GRAMS AT THE ASIAN LAW
CAUCUS. GREAT APP IN THIS THESE
GOT MANY NICOLE FONG AND
COMMUNITY ADVOCATE FOR THE
VOTING RIGHTS INCENTIVES
PROGRAM AT ASIAN AMERICANS
ADVANCING JUST ASIAN AKAK OUR
TEAM WORKS INCREASE ACCESS TO
DEMOCRACY FOR HISTORICALLY
DISENFRANCHISED AN INMATE
COMMUNITIES. THIS BILL IS FOR
CLEAN UP BILL A FAIR AMOUNT.
THE EIGHT FOREIGN IT'S PAST
YOUR COMMITTEE LAST YEAR. AB
EIGHT FOUR NINE REFORM TO
CALIFORNIA'S LOCAL
REDISTRICTING THIS TO BE MORE
FAIR TRANSPARENT AND ACCESSIBLE
TO THE PUBLIC IT MANDATE THAT
CITIES AND COUNTIES RATHER MAPS
USING RAINS CRITERIA PRIORITIZE
NEIGHBORHOODS AND COMMUNITIES
OF INTEREST. I AND A PLACE NEW
PANTY IN PUBLIC AVERAGE
REQUIREMENTS ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND PROHIBITED
PARTISAN GERRYMANDERING AB
TWELVE SEVENTY SIX MAKES MIGHT
INCLUDE CHANGES AND BEING
CORPORATES LANGUAGE THAT CIVIL
RIGHTS GROUPS SEEKING ASIAN OR
ASIAN AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT
ASSOCIATIONS. UNDER DRAFTING
BUT WITH INADVERTENTLY DELETED
FROM THE- FOR INSTANCE AB EIGHT
FOUR NINE WAS SUPPOSED TO EXACT
CHARTER CITIES FROM FALLING THE
RANGE REDISTRICTING CRITERIA IN
THE BELL IF THERE CHARTER
ADDRESSES THREE DISTINCT
CRITERIA THAT LANGUAGE WAS
INADVERTENTLY DELETED FROM AB
FOR NOT. AN A. B. TOSS SIX
ADDED BACK IN AFTER IN QUESTION
FROM PRACTITIONERS IN THE FIELD
AB TWELVE TWENTY SIX MAKES
ACTUALLY CLEAR THAT UNDER
EXISTING OFF CHARTER CITIES CAN
CREATE REDISTRICTING COMMITTEE.
NOT AB EIGHT FOR AND I DID
NOTHING TO. POWER AB. X.
FURTHER CLARIFIES THAT THESE
COMMISSIONS ARE SUBJECT TO THE
SAME REDISTRICTING REQUIREMENTS
A CHARTER CITY WOULD NEED
FOLLOW. UNLESS OTHERWISE
EXEMPTED BY LAW. SO YES IN A
RETAIL SEVENTY SIX TO HONOR THE
COMPROMISES THAT SHAPE THE SLAM
OUR LOCAL LANDMARK LOCAL
REDISTRICTING BILL AND TO
PREVENT ANY FUTURE CONFUSION
AROUND REDISTRICTING CHARTER
CITIES THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. PLEASE AT JONATHAN STEIN
IMAGE PROGRAM AT A MARKAKIS
YOU'RE ONLY TO ANSWER LEGAL OR
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS THANK
RICHARD THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL MRS IN SUPPORT. HARD
LET'S DO IT FOR THE RECORD. I'D
HAPPILY LET YOU DO THAT BUT WE
SHOULD. GET EVERYTHING ON
RECORD. HOW CALIFORNIA ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU. CALIFORNIA
WE'RE PLANTERS OF AB EIGHT
FORTY NINE AND OF THIS BILL AND
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. SEEING NONE AND
BRING IT BACK- TED TO
COLLEAGUES ON THE COMMITTEE AND
JUST OF FOLKS KNOW- MR MAYS AND
MISTER CALDERON WILL NOT BE
JOINING US THIS MORNING AND NOT
BEEN REPLACED. ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
VERY CONCISE CLEAR-
PRESENTATION WHEN THE TIME
COMES. AND WE HAVE A QUORUM
I'LL BE HAPPY TO RECOMMEND
SUPPORT. ON THE BILL WHICH WILL
HAPPEN IN ABOUT TEN SECONDS.
HELLO. SO IT LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE
A QUORUM- SO CAN WE TAKE
RAWNESS OF A QUORUM BERMAN
HERE. GALLAGHER CALDERON LOW.
MAYES MULLIN WEBER WE HAVE A
QUORUM GREAT- AND WITH THAT I
GUESS I DIDN'T GIVE YOU THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CLOSE HIS
ACCOUNT OF THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY PRESENT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK DR A GREAT NOW
THAT WE DO HAVE A QUORUM. WE
MOTION AND A SECOND. LIKE I
MENTIONED. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE VOTE. BERMAN HI
BERMAN I GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER
NOT VOTING CALDERON IS ABSENT
LOW. LOW I MAYES IS ABSENT
MULLIN WEBER WEBER I. SO THAT
IS ON CALL ON A THREE TWO ZERO
VOTES AND WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN- FOR OTHERS TO ADD ON WHEN
THEY GET HERE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT
THEY'RE ON THEIR WAY. THAT
STANDING GOOD. AND THAT BRINGS
US TO ITEM NUMBER TWO ON OUR
AGENDA. MISTER LOLO AB TWELVE
FORTY FIVE THIS ITEM IS ON THE
AGENDA FOR VOTE ONLY SINCE THIS
ITEM IS ON THE AGENDA FOR VOTE
ONLY THERE WILL BE NO DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION OR PRESENTATION ON
THAT ITEM. AND SO DO WE HAVE A
MOTION TO APPROVE A. B. TWELVE
FORTY FIVE. WE HAVE A MOTION. A
SECOND. THAT MOTION SEEMS A LOT
OF FAIL FOR LACK OF A SECOND IN
THAT ITEM ON THE AGENDA IS
DISPENSED WITH. I WILL LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS TO ADD ON. AB TWELVE
SEVENTY SIX. AND WITH THAT WERE
DONE IT BUT THE MEETING IS NOW
ADJOURNED. AND TOLD. AS A
MEMBERS GET HERE THANK YOU
EVERYBODY BRIDGET. YEAH
. GREAT
SO LET'S LIFT THE CALL ON AB
TWELVE SEVENTY SIX BONTA MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE. CALL ABSENT
MEMBERS EMOTIONS TO PASS TO
COMMITTEE ON LOCAL GOVERNMENT
MULLIN. MULLIN ONLINE. AND WITH
THAT THE BILL PASSES OUT ON A
FORTY ZERO VOTE THE MEETING IS
ADJOURNED